oh let me ask you another ridiculous
thing before I ask you serious questions
um so Joe Rogan thinks that a tie
um
is an effective way to attack somebody I
don't know if I I can't believe I
haven't in the time in Vegas I didn't
talk to you about this I think it's not
have you ever explored this so as the
best choker in the world have you ever
explored the use because like Jiu-Jitsu
has the jacket but the tie
to me is a pretty shitty uh way to choke
somebody like intuitively it thinks like
it's a good way but it can slide around
it's it feels like if it feels like
there's no uh there's no way to really
pin you would need to
right so you use it the way you use a
belt yeah essentially yeah but then I
would guess so yeah
I don't I don't think it's and I think
if it gives you it actually has the
reverse effect which it gives you the
the false and circumference that you can
use it and instead you'll just distract
you so what you think is a stronger way
than the color
or just a strong way yeah
yeah I don't see how
maybe just like in a street fight
scenario right like um but by the time
you grab the tie the guy goes punch your
nose yeah what uh what George Saint
Pierre thinks is the best use of the
ties to actually like uh um
what do you call that
so basically to off balance them
which is an interesting point until I
make the decoration they used to yeah
but you could use the jacket for the
same kind of thing
yeah I don't know I haven't really fully
tested it it's a okay for that
perspective of unbalancing of balancing
the person he can be yeah because you
you know you have control of the
person's neck the color you know the
jacket moves so for the purpose of off
balance in the person I would agree with
George
see the thing is that's the thing about
martial arts is you can say all kinds of
[ __ ]
but until you really test it in uh over
a period of years the competition you
won't really know I think like that's
where my gut says
um just how easily the time moves
my gut says the collar there is
something really powerful about the
jacket there's like the way it sits I
mean the fact that the arms trap it from
rotating
yeah like it's a weird piece of clothing
it's a really dangerous piece of
clothing that we put on ourselves yeah
like and it's kind of cool that we've
developed this whole martial arts system
that allows you to use that to to do a
lot of damage it's very interesting so
when we're saying something that you
develop over the years of practice over
and over again going back to deficiency
of the amount of back by experience of
attacking people
they people always had a much higher
chance of escaping from the back then
from my mouth
so it's I feel if if I Mountain you get
both my hands on your neck you cannot
Escape you if my hands are deep
it's over like that I don't remember
anyone escaping but I do remember if my
hands are deep on your collar or even
the real naked choke is still a hassle
like it's not clean